do you think this is the unraveling of
the United Kingdom as it stands and we
likely to see Northern Ireland the
Scotland start to peel away well I think
it is going to be a very long term
unraveling when you think about two
supertankers that are heading towards
each other you know they can't get out
of each other's way but it's gonna be
quite a while before you actually see
metal-on-metal that's kind of what we're
looking at here I mean the Scots have no
incentive tomorrow to try announce a new
referendum in fact there was some polls
this morning that show that 55 to 42
Scots don't want another referendum
right now but you know if it turns out
that the UK is not able to get a very
strong integration agreement a Norway
style agreement with the EU over the
course of the coming months years then
the Scots I think very clearly are going
to then have a referendum the Scottish
National Party will be very strong
around that they'll get it they'll win
it they'll be out Northern Ireland I
don't know if we see a referendum but we
see enormous tensions dealing with the
land border with Ireland which now is
gonna have to be policed in some way
spot checks things like that's gonna
really creates problems between the
Catholics and the Protestants and
between Northern Ireland and England
especially because the end of the day
they're the poorest in the UK and they
were getting a lot of money from the
European Union that money's not coming
any more so certainly within the United
Kingdom you have to imagine you're gonna
see a slow-motion implosion over the
course of months and years in
good-morning
who's gonna provide leadership in Europe
is it gonna be angular Merkel and are
people gonna back her
well I mean ish I'm gonna merkel is
still the strongest leader in europe but
you know before brexit it was very clear
that europe wasn't being led very
effectively there was growing populism
in all of these countries not just in
the UK there was growing opposition to
brussels growing euro scepticism that
that doesn't go away with brexit it's
actually going to intensify and and
while merkel is the adult in the room
she's pragmatic she's saying we don't
want to punish the UK you know sort of
just for spite and we don't want to
force them to leave immediately we
should give them some time it's very
clear if the Germans are going to be
looking out for Germany's interests and
also German political domestic interests
and so ultimately I don't think that
Germany's going to be able to ride
roughshod over other countries the
politics for brexit are negative for the
EU process of Greece the politics were
let's keep everybody in even though it's
economically painful in brexit there
would be economic benefits for having
more integration but the politics for
all of the leaders across the EU is we
have to show everyone this is not a
viable outcome for any of them
particularly as you see the electoral
process in places like France and
Germany and Italy so Merkel's the leader
she's the adult but she's not gonna be
able to get this done do you think those
that argue that the UK should be
punished will take some heart from the
idea that it looks like the Spanish
electorate moved towards rahoy
as a result of brexit
I think that's a plus in Spain let's see
what happens in October with the Italian
referendum let's see what happens with
France I mean right now we have 38%
popular approval for the front Nationale
I mean if this was only Spain it'd be
great but unfortunately you know you
can't just have one data point I mean
there's Renzi's in Italy should the
shouldn't the rise of Renzi had meant
that we should take heart that there
wouldn't be a brexit no unfortunately
it's 28 different countries and they're
all moving in different directions most
of them moving away from integrated
Europe so I mean I I'm glad that there
are so many risks in Europe right now
and you're not gonna see all of them hit
it would have been great if we could
have avoided the brexit risk we avoided
the podemos risk this weekend in Spain
there are many many more some are going
they hit and and unfortunately they're
going to hit in the middle of what's
going to be a very long and very costly
and painful unwind Ian what happens
therefore in terms of timing because you
have France particularly on the
forefront wanting to get the UK with the
process of exiting as quickly as
possible
we've got Merkel's summoning summoning
Orland and Renzi to Berlin today she's
obviously going to try and get them on
the same page about timing should it be
a slow process should we have the
caution coming from Merkel or is quicker
better
well it can only be so slow we had you
know Cameron apparently said to his aide
yesterday you know why should I be left
with all the difficult [ __ ] he's not he
has no desire to negotiate that himself
so he's not I think that everyone's
going to give them until October when a
new prime minister and new government is
in place but at that point I think the
pressure from the Europeans will be
immense Osborne's idea that you don't
actually need to do anything until you
have clarity from the Europeans oh and
maybe you could wait for a year or two
that is going to be unacceptable to all
the Europeans and they will make the
Brits pay the UK will increasingly be
irrelevant in EU processes they won't be
allowed in meetings there'll be an
observer they'll be on the outside so
for everyone that's saying well maybe
they don't have to have a vote maybe
they could back into a second memorandum
maybe Parliament won't go maybe they
could wait on article 50 that's all
beautiful but the fact is the process
has been set in motion and as the unwind
continues if the Brits are obstreperous
or trying to walk it back the Europeans
are going to make it harder and the
flipside of bats is that if the
Europeans make it harder their own
populations are going to look at them
and say you know what you politicians
are out of touch right this works two
ways and it's a very fine line that
these European politicians now need to
walk a sharply negative reaction a
fearful reaction is only gonna tell
those that believe that the EU is not
working but they are on the right track
well that's that's true when it's one of
the reasons why the Europeans want this
done quickly unfortunately then the
Brits aren't negotiating against one
country one party if they would be easy
you know you've got East Europeans
across the board that look at this
process and say aha the populace are
already in power in countries like
Poland and Slovakia and Hungary and for
each of them they're going to use their
cooperation with Merkel as an
opportunity to ask for more goodies
themselves on things like Schengen and
refugees on issues like economic
transfers on issues around economic
nationalization this is not going to get
easier there's a reason why the Brits
voted for brexit it's because Europe
wasn't working there's an even if they
had voted remain Europe governance was
going to look worse over the coming
years and it's not because these
European governments can't shoot
straight it's because the structure
doesn't allow them to coordinate
properly so you're right
they're going to be incentives that say
damn it'd be better if we could just
work this out with the UK in a nice
civilized fashion Merkel you know first
among equals understands that but you
know Merkel first among equals wasn't
able to resolve the refugee crisis look
how hard it was to deal with Greece she
wasn't able to keep the UK and there is
no reason to believe that she's going to
be more successful in effectively
dealing with this unwind in fact there's
every reason to believe the opposite